Das Podcast auf. Warum darf man seine Community nicht scheiße finden eigentlich? Wie fandest du die Intros, die gekommen sind? Die neuen? Toll, ich fand die alle super. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Intros. Was hat dir besonders gefallen an den neuen Intros, die so reingekommen sind? Vor allem die 1 zu 1 kopierten Loops aus GarageBand. Ah, okay. Die findet ihr, weil ich weiß nicht, wenn man mit Garageband vertraut ist, dann hört man diese Garageband Loops überall. In ganz vielen Podcastintros, von kleinen Podcasts. YouTube-Videos auch. Ja, total viel. Und ich glaube, viele kennen die aber einfach nicht als Garagebandintros. Deswegen denken die sich, wow, was für ein fetziger New York-Style-Jazz-Chinel. Ich war mal so sauer auf dich. Ich habe mal in so einem komischen Anflug eines Höhenfluges gemeint, ich schreibe jetzt mal ein Orchesterstück in Garageband. Und habe mir wirklich ewig lang daran gesessen, ein Orchesterstück geschrieben, dann habe ich es dir gezeigt und du meintest, ja, ganz cool, aber du hast ja so einen Loops gebaut, oder? Und ich dachte mir, was zur fucking Hölle. Auf der einen Seite Kompliment, weil es so klingt wie ein extra für GarageBand komponierter Loop. Aber auf der anderen Seite fand ich das so gemein. Und ich glaube, in dem Moment hast du gar nicht gemerkt, wie viel du Schaden in mir anrichtest. Ich weiß, ja. Seitdem habe ich auch nicht mehr komponiert. Habe ich wirklich deine Kompositionsknospe zerrückt? Ja, es hätte so ein pathetisches Intro für Podcast-Opo werden können, aber es ist sehr pathetisch. Es klingt so ein bisschen wie das Intro von The Newsroom. So wahnsinnig, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt sagt jemand, hält gleich eine Rede auf die Nation. Das ist, glaube ich, wirklich die Serie mit dem grössten Kontrast zwischen Qualität des Intros und Qualität der Serie. Ich liebe das Intro. Das ist furchtbar. Na gut, visuell ist es furchtbar. Aber es ist auch musikalisch furchtbar. Für musikalisch finde ich es ganz toll. Du glaubst aber nicht, was Garageband für mich bedeutet. Also Garageband ist auf allen Mac-Produkten vorinstalliertes Musikprogramm, wo man selber Musik machen kann. Und früher, ich hatte ja schon Mac, schon bevor alle Mac hatten, was jetzt cool klingt, was in der Realität aber genau das Gegenteil von cool ist. Du hast diesen Satz auch schon gesagt, bevor den alle anderen gesagt haben. Ja, weil es bedeutet hat, dass ich nicht die Videospiele spielen konnte, die alle meine Freunde spielen konnten. Irgendwie, oh geil, ich zog Counter-Strike, ja, ich spiele Sims, was mir aber eine sehr, sehr grosse Liebe mit Blizzard beschert hat, weil man alle Blizzard-Spieler auf Max immer spielen konnte, was natürlich direkt der Weg in mein Herz war und weswegen auch so wütend war, dass man Overwatch, das aktuelle Spiel, nicht auf Max spielen kann, aber wir hatten Garageband, wir hatten nicht viel, aber wir hatten Garageband und Und tatsächlich, ein Freund von mir hatte auch Mac, und wir haben nur über Garageband kommuniziert. Wir haben dann immer so wirklich diese einzelnen Loops stundenlang angehört, weil früher war ja das Internet nicht da. Wenig war viel, kann man auch so. Genau, das heißt, alles, was man auf seinen 120 Megabyte auf der Festplatte gespeichert hat, that's it, das war der Kosmos, in dem man sich bewegt. Das eine U2-Album. Ich hatte tatsächlich ein Best-of-Robbie-Williams-Album, das ich mit 200 Mal angehört hat. Ich hatte den Herr der Ringe, die Gefährten-Soundtrack, 500 Mal angehört und ich hatte tatsächlich eine Simpsons-CD mit allen Liedern aus den ersten acht Simpsons-Staffeln. Wirklich? Brillant. Und auch so ein geniales Produkt. Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn man im Urlaub, und da kommen wir gleich zu dir, im Urlaub findet man die besten Sachen. Weil man das Gefühl hat, nicht nur sind es dieselben Produkte wie zu Hause in einer anderen Variante. Also statt Erdbeerschokolade zu Hause gibt es dann Paprikaschokolade in Ungarn. Sondern es ist eine ganz andere Art von Produkt. Und zwar habe ich dieses Simpsons-CD gekauft als eine Kombination aus Musik-CD und Puzzle. Puzzle? Das war eine Box, da war unten die CD drin und komplett oben aufgefüllt mit Puzzle. Und es ist so eine Kombo, wo man sich denkt, okay, ist das hier so, dass man immer das Album und ihr kriegt noch ein Puzzle dazu? Also irgendwann ist herausgefunden, dass alle Puzzle gleich gestampft sind. Das heißt, je nach Größe gibt es halt eine so eine große Presse. Ist das so? Und die presst das Bild in Puzzleteile zusammen, da wird ein Gemisch, dann kommt so eine Mischmaschine oder so gelangweilte Hausfrauen, die da am Kriegstehen. Aber kann man das Gitter nicht materieren? Nee, es wird nicht gedreht. Und da hat jemand herausgefunden, dass man einfach jedes beliebige Puzzle einer gleichen Größe ineinander puzzeln kann. Da hat jemand ein Pferd in der Lokomotive gepuzzelt, scheißegal. Riesige Verwirrung, das ist bis heute nicht wiedergeordnet. Aber das fand ich total interessant, dass man da so wenig, aber das ist auch jetzt, dass es auffällt. Im Jahre 2018 fällt irgendwie auf, alles war gleich, wir hätten uns nie anstrengen müssen. Das ist ja wie bei den Chicken Nuggets, wo es nur sechs Formen gibt. Bone, Bell, Boot and Ball. Es gibt den Ball, es gibt den Boot. Was? Ball, Boot, Bell and Ball. Bone, Boot, Bell and Ball. Bone, Boot, Bell and Ball. Es gibt den Bone. Den kennt jeder. Vorne dick, hinten dick, Mitte dünn. Der Knochen. Der Beste. Dann gibt es den Boot. Jeder kennt den Boot. Jeder kennt die Stiefelform. Jeder kennt die Stiefelform. Dann gibt es den Ball, klassisch rund. Und dann gibt es die Bell. Eine schmale Seite hat eine dicke Seite. Bone, Boot, Bell, Ball. Bone, Boot, Bell, Ball. Das ist ja unfassbar. Und es gibt nur diese vier. Naja gut, beim Bone hast du das ein bisschen übertrieben, das ist einfach ein Rechteck. Nee, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone, Bone. Das ist meine Wer-wit-Millionär-Frage. Wie heißt es, welches ist keine Form? Welches? Boneboot, Bell, Schade, dass es nur bis D geht. Leider. Nee, besser wäre sowas wie ein anderes anderes Wort mit B. Ja, oder welches... Ein englisches, vielbuchstabiges Wort mit B. Welches Lebensmittel hat die Formen Bone, Boot, Bell und Ball? Chicken Nuggets, Döner? Oh, nee. Mortadella? Welches ist keine Form? Bone, Bird, Bell, Boy. Und dann Bird. Das fand ich sehr interessant, das stimmt schon. Wahnsinn. Wo wir gerade bei Garageband-Loops waren, Midi, ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist, hat einen sehr grossen Teil meines Lebens eingenommen, Midi-Musik, die man immer so hergestellt hat mit seinem Yamaha. Ich hatte früher so ein Casio-Keyboard, da hab ich mal Midi-Musik mitgemacht. Keine Ahnung, es gibt Midi-Stecker, ist es eher Stecker, ist es eher ein Format, ich hab keine Ahnung. Aber ich dachte mir, als ich zum ersten Mal die Truman Show, den Film der Truman Show geschaut hab, dachte ich mir, die können ja keine ... Der kann ja in seinem Leben, wenn er Radio hört, ist eine Fernsehsendung, wenn Truman Radio anmacht, können die ja kein echtes Lied spielen. Der hat bestimmt in seinem Leben nur Midi-Musik. Nur so gamerfreie Scheissmusik gehört. Oh Gott, der Arme. Und eigentlich finde ich, es ist ein toller Film an sich und die Prämisse ist noch besser als der Film und ich würde mir wünschen, dass es da noch einen zweiten Teil zu gäbe. Ja, aber das ist so richtig. Kannst du per Definition keinen zweiten Teil machen? Er geht noch mal rein, hat er seinen Schlüssel vergessen? Er hat angelassen. Nee, aber er hat so ein paar Sachen kannst du per Definition keinen zweiten Teil machen er geht nochmal rein, hat er seinen Schlüssel vergessen oder was, wie soll das ausgehen? Er hat angelassen nee, aber er hat so ein paar Sachen liegen lassen einfach, so die Musik, die er mal gehört hat er kommt in der echten Welt jetzt auch nicht klar das will ich sehen, ich will sehen, wie er in der echten Welt nicht klarkommt und sich selbst so eine Welt um sich herum baut vielleicht Social Media wäre genau sein Ding was war das denn gerade? In der Moderation-Schule wird immer noch viel vorbereitet. Nicht, dass Fliegen plötzlich einen angreifend in die Nase fliegt. Doch, in der Frank-Elsa-Matter-Klasse haben wir in einem Fliegenraum moderieren müssen. Na toll, aber ihr wart in Europa die einzige Journalistenschule mit einem Fliegenraum, das weiß jeder. Ja, aber ist es nicht eher andersrum, war es nicht so, dass die eher Werbung gemacht haben in der Welt,
dass der dann irgendwie immer die Produkte angepriesen, dass der Nachbar immer gesagt hat, hey, wollen wir nicht mit unserem neuen Fisco-Rasenmäher den Rasenmäher? Und dann Truman so, ich hasse den Fisco. Und alle so, wo, wir schalten um, Werbung, mach Werbung. Ah, du Quatschkopf. Ich weiss auch vor allem, das ist ja immer so, ich glaube, meine Garageband-Hysterie ist genau in die Zeit gefallen, in der ich mir ein Instrument aussuchen wollte. Und ich war lange noch bei Trompete, mein Leben hätte insgesamt anders verlaufen. Aber du siehst auch aus wie Trompeter, das ist eine Trompeterfigur. Und dann gab es aber bei Garageband die Kategorie oder diese Art Clip Acoustic Noodling. Acoustic Noodling. Und mich hat da so fasziniert Acoustic Noodling. Vielleicht kann man was vorspielen aus der Kategorie Acoustic Noodling, dass ich mir dachte, ich will auch akustisch nudeln. Und ich will das auch machen. Auch das Englischverständnis als Kind war ja damals nicht so krass, wie es heute fiel. Rumnudeln. Rumnudeln. Ich will einfach ein bisschen auf einer Gitarre rumnudeln. Und so habe ich mir dann gegönnt. Was ist nudeln? Und allein, ich habe, glaube ich, hunderttausend Tracks gemacht. Immer wieder die Trompeter. Weil da gab es zwei, die haben genau zusammengepasst. Yes. Ja, das war großartig. Aber das ist interessant. Aber es war grossartig. Babababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababababab einem Grund mehr Loops als alle anderen. Irgendwo, ich glaube, es kam von meinem Vater, der war ein großer Mac-Fan, und der hatte das Mac-Magazin. Und ich glaube, da war man bei einer CD dabei mit so Bonus-Sachen für Garageband. Und dann kannte jemand ein Loop nicht und du hast gesagt, der habe ich selber komponiert. Und plötzlich hatte ich mehr und da waren nicht nur zusätzliche Loops dabei, sondern auch fertige Songs. Also wirklich so ein... Hier, Anna, den habe ich für dich komponiert. Ja, aber wirklich so einfach so ein richtig ordentlicher Rocksong, so richtig mit Gitarre, Bass, allem und dann auch wirklich den richtigen Komponenten, die so ein Song hat, mit Chorus und dann der Zwischenteil. Und dann irgendwie habe ich das auf dem Rechner gehabt und dann war ich halt bei Freunden
und dann ist er so, ja, hört es euch mal
an irgendwie, habt ihr einfach mal was zusammengeschmissen,
ein bisschen rumgenudelt, guckt mal an und alle so
What, das hast du gemacht?
Bevor der Sänger einen Satz wieder auf Stopp gedrückt.
Bevor Freddie Mercury
einstimmen konnte.
Und ja.
Dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm, dum Dieses einfach zu präsentieren. Also weißt du, macht man das vielleicht subtiler? Nee, ich habe vorhin probiert, dass man in einem Alter, es ging viel
um Status im Kindergarten.
Und in einem Alter muss man sagen,
wo niemand der anderen was
geleistet hat, meinte man selber,
was leisten zu müssen.
Im Endeffekt hat, glaube ich, niemand was geleistet.
Und es ging oft darum, Dinge von anderen
kaputt zu machen.
Weil ich glaube, es ist sehr selten so,
auch in dieser Dokumentation ja so,
von den Jungs allein zu Hause, die haben halt nichts gebaut.
Und ich glaube, es ist wirklich etwas, was für Kinder spricht.
Die Kälte sind in der Mitte der Welt. kaputt zu machen. Ja. Weil ich glaube, es ist sehr selten so, es war auch in dieser Dokumentation ja so, von den Jungs allein zu Hause, die haben halt nichts gebaut. Und ich glaube, es ist wirklich was, was für Kinder spricht. Die kriegen nichts hin. Die machen eher Dinge kaputt. Kaputt machen ist besser, sind die wesentlich besser drin als im Aufbauen. Ja. Das ist interessant. Ich meine, es kam natürlich irgendwann raus, dass der Song geklaut war. Natürlich, irgendwann kam dieses Update auch für alle anderen. Und dann hat jeder von diesen Freunden, jeder meiner drei Freunde, die es gehört haben, für sich alleine zu Hause bemerkt, der Florentina hat mich einfach angelogen. Das gibt's nicht. Aber es wurde natürlich nie an mich herangetragen. Nein? Nein, du kannst ja nicht sagen, hey, der Song, den du mir vor dem Jahr gezeigt hast, der war nicht von dir. Also es war, manchmal war es schwach.
Ich teile mein Leben in so ein paar Kapitel ein.
Und ein Kapitel Kindheit endet mit, als ich herausgefunden habe, es heisst Garage Band und nicht Garage Band. Ja.
Weil das ist eines dieser Dinge, die man nur sieht.
Jeder weiss, was gemeint ist.
Du siehst es geschrieben und du denkst Garage, Garage.
Ja.
Ja, das ist aber Garage. Garageband, Garageband. Mir geht es nicht gut. Ich habe die schlimmste Mischung aus wahnsinnigem Hunger, pochende Kopfschmerzen und wahnsinnige Müdigkeit. Was ist los mit dir? Jetlag, glaube ich. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Oh, dann kommen wir jetzt zur grossen Top-Story-Docking-Folge. Nee! Heute ist übrigens Folge 150, ist dir das klar? Nein. Das ist die unspektakulärste Jubiläumsfolge aller Zeiten. Ey, nichts an dem, was wir gerade gesagt haben, ist dem würdig. Nee, aber ich meine, wir haben jetzt ein Achteltausend. Nee, 125 ist ein Achteltausend. Ja, stimmt.
Wir sind jetzt ein Siebteltausend.
Ja, in etwa.
Siebenkommazweiteltausend.
Wir kommen der Sache schon näher.
Aber Halbtausend sagt man nicht.
Also man sagt ja eine halbe Million, aber man sagt nicht halbtausend.
Halbtausend.
Aber vor allem, was hat Tausend für einen Artikel? Also man sagt ja die Millionen. Der Tausi? Der Taui? Der Tausender? Der Tausend. Der Tausender. Die Tausend, würde ich sagen. Die Tausend? Die Tausend. Ich habe eine halbe Tausend. Ja. Ich habe ein halbes Tausend. Hühner. Und dann der Mathelehrer. Was denn? Kartoffeln, Gramm, Sportbeutel, Pflaumen. Fuck you, Mathelehrer, ich hab die Einheit vergessen. Es geht um die fucking Einheit, es geht darum, dass ich nicht auf die Zahl kam, wenn die richtig war. Was? Und immer alle Mathelehrer haben immer gesagt, was denn, Kartoffeln, Gramm. Es geht darum, dass ich die Frage nicht verstanden habe und da Nasenbluten auf das Papier hatte und nichts hingeschrieben habe. Das ist das eigentliche Problem, Herr Lehrer. Das sind die Probleme eines Kindes. Und Nina, die guckt mich schon seit einer Woche mit dem Arsch nicht mehr an, obwohl ich sie liebe. Ja, da fehlt den Lehrern dann auch einfach das Feingefühl, um mit den Kindern umzugehen. Vor allem, ich habe letztens so eine Doku gesehen über Mobbing, und da war es so dieses ... Dein Leben. Wow, es war ein Spiegel. Und da habe ich, da ist ja so diese Fantasie, die viele haben, so den Mobber konfrontieren. Also so nochmal irgendwie keine Ahnung. Halt, stopp. Ja, aber auch jetzt keine Ahnung, du wirst gemobbt dein Leben lang und dann bist du irgendwie super krass. Und dann konfrontierst du den Mobber nochmal so von wegen so, na, was bist du jetzt und was bist ich jetzt und dann
mobbst du zurück. Da sind Filme halt oft misleading,
weil am Ende jedes Films machen
das halt alle Hauptfiguren, gehen am Ende zurück
zum Mobber und besiegen den halt
und das ist halt einfach falsch, das passiert im Echten nämlich.
Ne, weil der Mobber
nimmt dir immer noch deinen Rucksack weg und wirft den
Mülleimer auf, wenn du Bill Gates bist.
Mobber haben keine Character-Arc.
Mobber haben immer gewonnen am Ende. Und vor allem diese ganze Doku baut darauf auf, dass am Ende dieses Mädchen, das gemobbt wurde in der Schule, die ganze Zeit. Und dann so, ja, wie war das für dich, ja, schrecklich und so. Und du denkst immer, okay, geil, am Ende gehen die da hin zu dem Mobber und machen den fertig. Und dann wird der gefilmt und dann irgendwie, ah, jetzt hier, ich bin in der Doku und du nicht. Und dann, ah, was sagst du denn, was fällt dir ein und so. Und dann am Ende konfrontieren sie den Mobber und der Mobber einfach so, ne, ich kann mich da nicht dran erinnern. Doch, du hast mich doch immer geärgert. Nö. Abspann. Einfach unbefriedigend ist das Ende einer Doku einfach. Schrecklich, wo ich mir denke, ich habe mir jetzt 25 Minuten lang angehört, was sie für eine schreckliche Kindheit hatte. Und am Ende habe ich nicht mal den, wo ich dann sage, so, aber jetzt bist du der Doofe. Das fand ich auch das Schlimmste bei Making the Murderer, wo du diese Serie guckst und die ganze Zeit denkst du, das ist ja wirklich ein Commitment. Das sind zehn Folgen, eine Stunde. Und du guckst die ganze Zeit dem zu und denkst, das kann nicht sein, dass der im Knast ist. Und dann kommt ab Folge fünf ein Zeitsprung und du denkst, oh fuck, und er ist immer noch im Knast. Und er muss doch endlich mal freikommen. Und dann denkst du, dann geht es am Ende ja so ein bisschen aufwärts und du denkst, okay, da hat irgendwie die Verteidigung noch ein paar Beweise an den Tag gelegt und so ein paar Sachen in Frage gestellt, die die Staatsanwaltschaft gefunden hat. Okay, wir kriegen das hin, wir kriegen das hin. Und dann plötzlich, ich wusste nicht, was das die letzte Folge ist, die letzten zehn Minuten in der letzten Folge, kommt ein Zeitsprung, wir springen achtzehn Jahre in die Zukunft, und er ist immer noch im Gefängnis. Und du denkst, what the fuck? Und dann ... Und du denkst, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich hab zehn Stunden geguckt, für einen Scheiss, und dann ... Klar, die Botschaft am Ende ist natürlich so stärker, dass das fucking amerikanische Rechtssystem gewisse Fragen aufwirft. Aber trotzdem, man ist einfach gewohnt, Gut, Dokumentationen haben halt kein Happy End, natürlich nicht. Die haben keinen Spannungsbogen, die haben gar nichts am Ende. Und dann, das fand ich so frustrierend, wirklich Zeitsprung, 17 Jahre in die Zukunft und erst immer noch im Gefängnis. Ciao! Das war heftig. Ja, das ist ein bisschen das Problem, jede Geschichte macht ja so ein Versprechen, hör mir zu, am Ende, ich hab schon eine Idee, wo es hin geht. Am Ende hat es sich gelohnt, dass es da geblieben ist. Am Ende hat es sich gelohnt, aber die Realität ist halt nicht so. Aber ich meine, bei Filmen manchmal funktioniert es halt auch nicht so. Das ist dann auch so das Problem, wenn man nicht merkt, dass es die letzte Folge war. Das passiert mir oft bei Serien, dass ich nicht merke, dass es die letzte Folge war. Und dann war es das Staffelfinale und du denkst, was? Und dann denkst du, oh Mensch, ja Gott, kam jetzt aber lange keine Folge mehr. Man geht anders rein in eine Folge, wenn man weiß, es ist das Staffelfinale. Das stimmt. Ich glaube, es ist auch ein befriedigenderes Ende, wenn du weißt, dass das Ende ist. Ja, ja. Weil du dir denkst hat der nochmal die Lektion gelernt, dass er vielleicht. Und wenn du daran nicht auf und nicht achtest und du immer noch auf Folge neun eingestellt bist, dann funktioniert es nicht. Es gibt verschiedene Serien, wo ich immer noch auf neue Folgen warte, aber die sind seit Jahren aus, das war's. Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch was wir gerade sagen, was wir so lustig hier vor uns herwerfen mit die Realität ist nicht wie die Dokumentation, aber ich glaube, genau das ist der Grund, warum ich das mache, was ich mache, also warum wir beide eher dann Fiction machen oder eher Comedy machen und aus der Realität damit fliehen, weil wir beide kommen nicht klar. Wir können uns das Ende schreiben, dass wir eine Realität nicht sind. Ja, wir können uns unseren Mobber so schreiben, dass wir am Ende die Sieger sind. Ja, dass es zum Kampf kommt oder dass nicht fucking Darth Vader sagt, ne ne, ich weiss nicht, wer das ist. Ich dachte, das wäre der Vater vielleicht. Hä? Nö, ich kann ihn nicht. Gut, dann fahr ich jetzt wieder. Und du willst nicht noch was sagen, ne? Ciao. Wer hat das fucking Skript geschrieben, Mann? Hier passiert gar nichts am Ende. Ne, mein Drehbuch kommt auch nicht zum Kampf am Ende. Ich will ja nicht kämpfen. Ne, ich meine, der Todesstern ist gross. das dauert erst mal, bis Luke ihn gefunden hat, Darth Vader. Oh, wo ist es du? Der muss sich erst mal durch die ... Hallo? Sorry, ganz kurz, Entschuldigung, Darth Vader? Oh, den habe ich zuletzt vor drei Dekaden Herrsein gesehen. Okay, nur weil es eine Science-Fiction-Welt ist, ist Dekitat des Wort. Gib mir jetzt zwei Dukaten und ich lasse dich vielleicht durchs Tor. Gut, also drei Kreuze und hilfst mir weiter, alles klar. Hier gehen sie einfach durch die Tür. Ich lasse die Münze springen. Lass die Münze springen, Cowboy. Okay. Und so durch 500 Räume bist du endlich bei Darth Vader angekommen. An müden Leuten kommt man da vorbei. In der Serie könnte man das machen.
Wusstest du, dass der Todesstern am Ende von Episode 4 gar nicht mehr eine Bedrohung da sein sollte?
Bis zur fast letzten Schnittfassung hat Luke den Todesstern zerstört,
ohne dass der nochmal den Planeten, um den er kreist, ja, wenn viel, glaube ich, bedroht hat und angefangen hat zu schießen. Und Luke hat es ja im letzten Moment geschafft, diese Katastrophe abzuwenden und Todesstern zu zerstören. In allen Schnittfassungen davor hat der Todesstern nichts gemacht, er hat einfach angegriffen. Absurd, ne? Vor allem, wenn es da nicht klappt, versuchen sie einfach nochmal. Ja, genau, versuchen sie es nochmal. Okay, Plan zwei Dienstag. Ich habe theoretisch unendlich Laserschüsse, wir können das eine Zeit lang durchhalten. Ich habe dir letztens geschrieben, was soll diese in der Einflugschneise, ja wie ein Vier, grosser Endkampf, Episode Vier, ach deswegen Vier, warum, Luke hat doch dann diese Klappe vor dem Gesicht, dass er nichts mehr sehen kann, warum macht er das? Das ist doch der Autopilot, oder nicht? Das ist auch keine Klappe, wo man nichts mehr sehen kann. Dem hat vor diesem Acht-Bit-Monitor. Aus Retrogründen haben die sich gedacht, lass uns so Acht-Bit-Sachen reinbauen. Wir können es doch mit Lasern schießen, aber keine Ahnung, wie 4K gehen soll. Er klappt das Visier weg. Autopilot weg. Und dann hat er ja freie Sicht und kann mit seinen eigenen Augen hingucken und dann gelingt es ihm. Mit der Macht. Aber der Helm, mit dem er trainiert, mit dem Laserball, der hat schon so ein Visier, wo man einfach nichts mehr sieht. Was ist das für ein Helm? Eine Augenbinde nehmen können. Aber gut, man hat sich einfach... Das ist Science Fiction. Ach so meinst du das ja. Aber warum gibt es
diese Helme, die einfach Klappen haben, wo man
nichts... Übungshelme für angehende Jedi.
Aber das ist der letzte Jedi, den es gibt.
Und ich meine, der Helm...
Sauviele Helme rumfliegen noch. Aber der Helm ist
doch auf dem Millennium-Ferkel.
Warum haben die so einen Helm, so einen Jedi-Trainingshelmen?
Obi-Wan hat in seiner Nike-Tasche mitgenommen.
Obi-Wan hat nichts mitgenommen.
Ich meine, warum sieht der
genauso aus wie die X-Wing-Helme?
Jedi und die Rebellenallianz haben
mit Obi-Wan hat in seiner Nike-Tasche mitgenommen. Obi-Wan hat nichts mitgenommen. Ich meine, warum sieht der genauso aus wie die X-Wing-Helme? Jedi und die Rebellenallianz haben jetzt erstmal nichts miteinander zu tun. Du, ich kenne die Scheiß auch noch aus irgendwelchen YouTube-Videos und irgendwelchen Websites, angelesene Scheißwissen. Du warst nicht auf Star-Wars-Cons. Nee, da wird über andere Sachen gesprochen. Du hast Jetlag? Wo warst du denn? Ach nö, gerade einfach. Ich bin müde vom Tag, einfach hören bis hin. Nee, ist ja ausgefallen, die Folge. Es kam sehr viel Wut von euch, zurecht. Nee, nicht zurecht, weil wir früher angekündigt haben, dass zwei Wochen ausfallen, wir haben sogar noch voraufgezeichnet. Wir dachten, wow, jetzt freuen sie sich. Nee, es kam Hass, weil trotzdem meine Folge ausgefallen ist. Ich war in Mexico in Mexico. Damals die Caballeros. Ich war in Mexiko, das war wirklich interessant. Eine Woche in Mexiko, zehn Tage war ich da, fantastisch, wirklich ein es war, ich dachte, ich wollte den Urlaub nutzen, um mich mal ein bisschen zu erholen. Keine Chance, Mexiko ist einfach ein wildes Land, ohne Regeln, komplette Anarchie. Das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen. Das Autofahren war einfach der absolute Horror. Ich hatte so einen kleinen Mietwagen, mit dem man da rumfährt halt. Und das ist saugefährlich. Hier bin ich fünf Unfällen ausgewichen, dann kommen plötzlich, weil die die Geschwindigkeit, niemand hält sich an Regeln. Also, und stellt euch mal vor, es gibt tendenziell Regeln im Strassenverkehr, jetzt hält sich aber niemand dran.
Niemand hält sich aber niemand dran.
Niemand hält sich an Geschwindigkeitsvorgaben. Was macht man dann als Regierung? Richtig, man baut etwas in die Straße ein, das einem nicht gestartet ist, schneller zu fahren, sonst bist du tot. Die haben es genannt, Toppe, diese Hübel. Ja, Geschwindigkeitshübel. Geschwindigkeitshübel. So, und die So, und die sind im Straßenverkehr einfach. Jetzt haben die, nehmst die aber auch nicht so richtig ernst mit Beschilderungen und Warnschildern. Und dann bin ich vom Flughafen direkt nach Tulum gefahren, das war die erste Strecke. Und es war schon dunkel und ich bin mit 130 Sachen drüber gefahren und dann kam einfach eine Tope. Und dann ist das Auto abgehoben. Ich meine, mein Stirn ist direkt gegen das Autodach gestossen, alle Mitfahrer haben geschrien, es war wirklich, es war schlimm. Und dann vor mir, dann war Stau und vor mir krabbelte ein Baby auf der Hutablagerung und der Kofferraum hat gesprochen wie so ein Riesenmund, der einem sagt, der einem auslacht auf Mexikanisch, der ist einfach mal auf und zu gegangen.
Und wenn du um Brücken fährst, dann fährst du wie so Wellen, weil die Brücken nicht so gebaut sind,
dass sie gerade Strassen erhalten können.
Es ist einfach ein wildes Land und da muss man sich
dran gewöhnen. Und die ersten drei Tage waren
ich wahnsinnig anstrengend, ich habe die ganze Zeit geschwitzt,
weil es so warm war und weil ich Angst hatte, panische Angst.
Irgendwann gleicht man sich
so ein bisschen an. Es ist wahnsinnig viel Verkehr, es ist wahnsinnig laut die ganze Zeit. Es war nicht so erholsam, wie ich dachte. Aber die Reise war ja auch nicht zum Spaß, ich wollte halt Maya, die Maya wieder fällen, weil die Maya sind weg. Die Maya sind einfach verschwunden. Es war eine Hochkultur, die haben vor Tausenden von Jahren gelebt. Manche von denen haben vor Christus schon gelebt. die haben krasse Bauten gebaut. Zu ihrer Zeit war das die entwickelste Zivilisation auf der ganzen Erde. Deren Tempelanlagen waren das Rom, das New York der damaligen Zeit und die sind einfach verschwunden. Die Leute sind einfach abgehauen. Man weiß nicht genau, warum diese Zivilisation einfach geendet hat. Und man weiß nicht, wo die Maya sind. Manche sagen, von Aliens abgeholt und so weiter. Und ich dachte mir, da gehe ich immer auf die Spur. Und deswegen Mexiko, nicht wegen Strand oder so. Klar, da ist da halt zufällig Strand. Naja, ich sag mal so, am Ende habe ich sie gefunden, aber es war ein Abenteuer. Ich bin dann wirklich auf so ein paar, ich war an drei verschiedenen Maya-Ruinen, das ist nicht zu empfehlen, das ist wirklich richtig cool, und bei einer hatte ich so einen coolen Guide, der Mexikaner, der einfach da die ganze Zeit rumläuft und Leuten das zeigt, und der ist, den kannst du einfach, der gibt so 50 Euro, der hat auch Euro genommen, komischerweise, und das ist sein Job, und der führt da dich halt rum, und da waren wir irgendwie zu dritt oder so, und der hat uns da rumgeführt, und der hat uns dann alles über die Maya erklärt, und das ist fantastisch, weil die hatten sogar, da gibt es ja diese große, ich war in Chichen Itza, das ist diese große Pyramide, die man kennt auch, wenn man an Maya denkt, genau, denkt man immer zuerst an diese Pyramide, und das ist ein Riesengelände, da gibt es auch noch andere, die haben auch ein Planetarium gehabt, so eine Sternwarte quasi, wo sie den Himmel beobachtet haben. Die Pyramide ist quasi auch als Kalender aufgebaut. Und die haben getippt, ein Jahr hat ungefähr 360 Tage. Die haben es also verdammt noch mal genailed fast. Und dann nebenan gibt es andere große Bauten. Ich habe gefragt, was ist das, können wir nicht da hin zuerst gehen? Er so, ja, okay, cool. Und dann sind wir da hingegangen, weil die meisten interessiert das gar nicht so richtig. Aber das ist eine Sportanlage, das war eine Arena. Die haben Sport gemacht. Und das ganze Gebäude, mir hat sich nicht erschlossen, was sie da gespielt haben. Weil man muss sich das so vorstellen. Es sind zwei längliche, riesenlängliche Bauten gegenüber voneinander. In ungefähr, sagen wir mal, 25 Meter Abstand voneinander hast du grosse, längliche Bauten. Also du hast ein Plateau, was wie eine Bühne erst, und dann geht so eine Schräge ab, wie so eine Halfpipe, und dann oben hast du auf beiden Seiten in der Mitte dieser länglichen Gebilde einen Ring. Der Ring steht so ab in die Mitte, sozusagen, dass man, wenn man guckt, längs am Gebilde lang guckt, kann man oben in den Ring reingucken. Und das war auf der anderen Seite auch. Es sah lustigerweise aus wie Quidditch. Und dann hab ich gefragt, was da gespielt wurde. Und nebenan lief so ein deutscher Guide her, so ein offizieller Guide, der hat ganz laut auf Deutsch gesagt, und niemand weiß, was wir hier gespielt haben für Sport. Ciao, weitergehen, wir gehen zur Pyramide, da könnt ihr auch Fotos machen. Und der Typ, Manuel, hat halt alles gewusst. Er hat alles darüber gewusst, weil er mit Nachfahren der Meier gesprochen hat, was wir gespielt haben. Und das war wirklich fantastisch und er hat uns das erklärt. Und es ist ein wahnsinniger Sport. Du hattest nämlich einen Ball, einen Lederball, und die haben Fussball gespielt im Prinzip. Du konntest nicht mit dem Kopf, mit den Armen, mit den Händen und so, konntest du nicht mit dem Ellenbogen, konntest du wiederum, konntest den Ball berühren und musst zu deinen Teammitgliedern spielen. Sechs gegen sechs, die einen standen an der ... Und das Feld ist halt ... Also, wenn man sich das Rechteck vom Fussball vorstellt und die beiden Tore, muss man das Feld dann einmal umdrehen um 90 Grad.
Das heißt, du spielst von der langen Seite auf die lange Seite, wie gesagt, und in der Mitte ist dieser Ring.
Und dein Käpt'n steht quasi im Tor des Gegners, also auf dieser Bühne gegenüber.
Die einen laufen in die Richtung, die anderen laufen in die Richtung.
Und der Käpt'n steht oben und er hat so eine Lederausrüstung an seinem Arm, an seinem rechten Arm, Ellenbogen. Und du musst deinen Ball zu deinem Käpt'n hochspielen, der muss den annehmen mit dem Fuß oder mit der Brust und muss ihn dann mit dem Ellenbogen hoch, quasi Ellenbogen hochschnell den Ball durch den Ring bringen. Ach, der wiederum in der Mitte des Feldes ist. Der Ring ist in der Mitte des Feldes. Zwischen den Bühnen. Nee, der hängt oben, über der Bühne quasi. Also es gibt zwei Ringe. Es gibt zwei Ringe, wie Tore, genau. Und den muss man durch, wie Kveditsch dann quasi. Und das ist halt sehr hoch. Und der Ball ist relativ groß im Vergleich zum Ring. Das heißt, das hat fast niemand jemals geschafft. Und das Spiel war vorbei, da merkt man, okay, die waren clever, die waren nicht so clever, weil sobald einer es jemals geschafft hat, war das Spiel vorbei. Das hat manchmal einen Monat gedauert, im schlimmsten Fall mehrere Jahre haben die gespielt. Problem ist, die hatten halt kein Licht oder sowas, Die sind halt immer, wenn es dunkel wurde, nach Hause gegangen und haben nächstes Jahr weitergespielt. Es sind Leute gestorben bei dem Spiel und so. Er hat mir das von Messern erzählt, und dann gab es auch so eine Wandzeichnung gezeigt. Ich glaube, die haben sich auch umgebracht während des Spiels. Sicher bin ich mir nicht. Ich glaube, es ging primär darum, den Ball rumzuspielen. Oder Hot Dogs verkauft. Ja ist schwer zu sagen. Chicken fingers, man weiß es nicht genau. Lustigerweise war halt der Typ, der das geschafft hat, mit dem Ball das da durchzubringen, der war einfach ein Held. Der war, es galt als von den Göttern ausgewählt, so sehr ausgewählt, dass er dann getötet wurde. Aber er wollte das. Ja, na gut, aber kein Wunder, dass die Spiele lange dauern, wenn der Gewinner getötet ist. Huch, jetzt dann doch daneben. Hups, hab's daneben geschafft. Huch, oi, jetzt bin ich ausgerutscht. Ja, und der hat's dann nicht geschafft. Das ist das schlechteste Motivationsthema, das ich mir vorstelle. Ja, aber die wollten das tatsächlich sehr gern. Die wollten halt ausgewählt werden und sterben, weil für die war das Afterlife halt so einfach ein riesen Thing. Das fand ich wahnsinnig lustig. Ich muss mal Bilder hochladen, weil das ist unfassbar, das ist eine riesen Arena quasi und rechts und links standen die ganze Zeit Leute und haben gejubelt, tausende mit dem Maya. Monate lang. Irgendwann war auch dann schwierig, also irgendwann steht mir vor, ist einem auch egal, wer gewinnt. Kann jetzt mal irgendwen diesen scheiß Ball da rein Und das war wirklich sehr interessant. Ich bin mal, ich muss mal Bilder hochladen, das ist nicht so leicht zu beschreiben, aber das war deren Sport. Und dann war ich noch an einer anderen Maya-Pyramide, ganz woanders, kilometerweit woanders, und die hatten das in klein. Auch noch mal, da habe ich mich wahnsinnig gefreut. Für Kinder? Ja, für Kinder. Ja? Da ist das gleiche Gebäude. Die bringen Kinder um? Auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob die das zum Üben benutzt haben oder sowas, aber kilometerweit weg war eine andere Meierstätte und da habe ich das in klein wiedergefunden mit diesen Ringen und es war, da haben wir einfach, selbst das war ein beeindruckendes Gebäude, weil das einfach auch ziemlich groß ist. Da sind erwachsene Meier, die sind gestorben wahrscheinlich, um diese Sportstätte für Kinder zu bauen. Für den Nachwuchs einfach. Für den Nachwuchs. Weil die sich dachten, fuck, das dauert zu lange. Und unsere letzte Weltmeisterschaft hat 14 Jahre gedauert. Jesus, das ist ja gut. Die sind schon fantastisch, die Meier. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich war schon irgendwann traurig, da waren sieben Tage rum und ich habe keinen Meier gefunden. Und dann, bei der letzten Meierstätte, wo ich war, war ich schon traurig. Ich bin oben auf die Pyramide geklettert, habe über den ganzen Urwald geschaut, das ist wirklich fantastisch, in Coba, kannst du über den ganzen Regenwald schauen, den mexikanischen Regenwald, und da habe ich aber immer noch keine Meier gefunden, die waren immer nach wie vor weg. Und dann bin ich durch den Urwald gegangen nachts, weil es war schon sehr spät, die Sonne ging gerade unter. Und dann bin ich gegangen und zurück auf den Parkplatz, zurück zu dem Auto. Und da plötzlich kam so eine Hochzeitsgemeinschaft an, die dann da diese Gastronomie mieten, um dann da zum Beispiel nach der Hochzeit die Festivitäten zu feiern. Und dann kam die an und ich dachte mir, okay, cool, dafür wird es mittlerweile benutzt, die Kulturstätten der Maya, um zu heiraten. Dann bin ich zu meinem Auto gegangen und dann sah ich sie. Ein Maya-Kind. Die Nachkommen der Maya sorgen für einen lustigen Abend, für Leute, die heiraten. Die ziehen sich dann an, wie sie damals angezogen waren und so. Und da fuhr so ein Kind, im Fahrrad, über dem Parkplatz, im Kreis, auch angezogen wie ein Maya-Kind. Dann habe ich den Guide gefragt, wer das ist. Ja, das sind die Nachkommen der Maya.
Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, ich habe sie gefunden.
Die Nachkommen der Maya fahren mit dem Fahrrad
im Kreis,
irgendwo in Mexiko.
Und tatsächlich gibt es wahnsinnig viele
Nachkommen, die
auch, wenn man sich mit ihnen unterhält, dann
erzählen die auch was. Also die kriegen
Was können die denn erzählen?
Ich meine, was kannst du denn heute aus? Die meisten Sachen wissen wir auch. Stefan, erzähl mal von den Germanen. Erzähl mal, wie war das denn? Es gibt so manche, die dann nach und nach an Familienmitgliedern weitertragen, was sie wissen. Und viele Museen wissen auch nicht, was die sich immer weitertragen. Diese Sportart zum Beispiel, ich hätte da nicht so viel darüber gefunden, das ist schon ziemlich weird.
Und da meinte der Türgeil auch, dass es nach Mayer-Nachkommen sich wieder erzählen, wie das gespielt wurde und so weiter.
Manche Sachen sind nur im Besitz der Mayer geblieben jemals.
Ja, und haben sie dir gesagt.
Und ich jetzt.
Ja, und du.
Also bist du eigentlich ein Mayer jetzt auf einer Geburtstag?
Ich bin jetzt ein Mayer, ich wurde aufgenommen in den Stamm.
Also du bist zumindest Teil der Tradition.
Du musst es weitergeben.
Ich fand es wahnsinnig spannend.
Wahnsinn.
Es war schon interessant. Mexiko ist auch so, also ich habe dann da eine Airbnb-Wohnung gehabt, die war richtig cool. Und dann musst du halt immer einkaufen gehen in diesen Märkten da. Und es ist schon wie du sagst, es ist ein anderes Land, die alles anders haben, aber alles so ein bisschen schlechter. Es ist halt nicht wie Amerika, wo du halt einfach wahnsinnig viel Auswahl hast und dann hast du so ein Serial-Regal, was sich wegflasht. Das ist einfach die Auswahl in Deutschland, aber alles so ein bisschen, du merkst schon die Armut auf jeden Fall. Und gerade da, wo wir gewohnt haben, wir haben ja nicht am Strand da gewohnt, weil Tulum besteht eigentlich nur aus einer großen Strandstrasse, sondern wir waren weiter weg in der Innenstadt gewohnt und da waren die Strassen nicht mehr befestigt, es waren lauter Strassenhunde da. Und die Gegend war schon ziemlich gruselig, wo ich nachts auch nicht mehr rausgegangen wäre. Aber was dann wiederum cool war, am Dia de los Muertos, am Tag der Toten. Ah, da warst du da? Da war ich auch, darüber war ich ja da. Und ich dachte ja, dass es wie bei James Bond ist, dass dann alle sich verkleiden und eine gute Parade feiern. Das war eher so so ein Familienfeiertag und alle feiern für sich und am Strand kriegst du davon gar nichts mit, aber da war Nachtzeit, konnte ich nicht schlafen, weil wahnsinnig laut Musik war, nee, da habe ich mich die ganze Nacht einfach auf dem Balkon, um ein bisschen schwer in Polizei gerufen, Silencio, auf dem Balkon, Silencium, ich habe mich mit Latein durchgeschlagen, Silencio per favore, und dann und dann saß ich da am Balkon abends und hab einfach die Musik gehört, was total schön war, weil man so ein bisschen was von der Kultur mitbekommt. Toll. Das war wirklich schön, ja. Also Mexiko ist wirklich sehr zu empfehlen, ist aber eher ein Abenteuerurlaub gewesen als ein Erholungsurlaub. Hast du auch Fernsehen geschaut, mexikanisches Fernsehen? Nee, kein Fernsehen. Nee? Nee. Ich dachte, die haben so vielleicht ganz abgefahrene Fernsehshows. Haben die auch, das Radio war auch, das Radio war abgefahren genug für mich. Und Essen so, also ist es so ganz scharf alles? Sehr viel Scharf, sehr viel Burrito, Taco, das war alles schon sehr klischeehaft. Das ist ein bisschen klischeehaft hier, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Farita, Burrito, Taco, ich habe aber auch bis heute nicht verstanden, wo die ganzen Unterschiede sind. Das weiß niemand eigentlich. Empanadas, Tortillas. Was ist das? Tacos sind auch nicht hart immer und Tortillas waren nicht immer weich, von daher die Grenzen waren fließend in Mexiko. Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden. Ja, dass auch meine Mexikoreise hat, macht das mal. Aber wie ist so der Dschungel, also ist es wirklich so ganz dicht, dass man da nicht durch kann oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Ja schon, also wenn du da selber durchgehen willst, dann kommst du nicht durch, würde ich auch von abraten. Weil es wirklich so dicht bewachsen ist, dass man da gar nicht physisch durchkommt. Ja genau, wobei dieses Gebiet, wo da war, das war ja die Riviera Maya, die ist schon sehr bebaut, also da hast du dann auch viele Strassen usw. viele Strassen usw. Ich hab aber, weil ich dachte, wow, friedlicher Dschungel. Ich bin nämlich nachts dann von dieser Einmaier-Pyramide, wo ich relativ spät war, wo ich dann so einen Nachtpass bekommen habe, was so halt gruselig war, weil niemand da war. Und das war auch so eine Pyramide, wo man drauf konnte. Und normalerweise ist das wahnsinnig überlaufen, aber ich war halt so spät da, dass ich quasi fast alleine da war. Da waren drei andere Menschen auf diesem Riesengelände.
Und da bin ich dann nachts durch den Dschungel gelaufen, zurück zum Auto, wo ich dann den Mai auf dem Fahrrad getroffen habe. Und da dachte ich mir, komm, du nimmst mal den Dschungel auf,
wie friedlich das ist, wie weitläufig gerade niemand um mich herum ist. Und ich dachte mir,
wow, der friedliche Dschungel, das ist das Geräusch, was der Dschungel macht.
Es ist einfach wie so ein Tinnitus, Milliarden Zikaden.
Ja, es ist wahnsinnig schlimm.
Und dann aber zum Vergleich, fast beruhigender, eine mexikanische Innenstadt. Wahnsinnig lustig. Also das ist wirklich sehr viel Action. Selbst im Dschungel ist einfach wahnsinnig laut. Aber einfach diese Tiere, die einfach die Evolution dazugebracht hat, maximal nervig zu sein. Ja. Einfach so maxim... Geht's nicht mehr ein bisschen lauter? Ich glaube, Zikade ist sogar das lauteste Tier der Welt.
Ja, auch weil hier die Evolution versagt, weil die Tiere, die sich am besten vorschlannen, die am lautesten sind,
also werden die immer lauter, eben mal lauter.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und irgendwann ist die Erde nicht mehr zu ertragen.
Ja, das stimmt. Wo ist das Maximum?
Wenn man einfach selbst hier die Zikaden aus Meier aus Meierstagen hören würde, einfach konstant.
Wahnsinn.
Gibt es Tiere, die ihre Ohren zumachen können?
Also so wie so Ohrenlieder haben, die einfach dann so...
Das weiß ich nicht.
Weil es ja schon, also ich meine, das Gehör ist ja interessant, weil das Gehirn das Gehör ja am besten ausblenden können muss, weil es ja konstant Signale bekommt. Das heißt, das Gehirn ist besonders gut darin, halt so konstante Geräusche rauszufiltern und sowas rauszunehmen, weil bei Augen sagt das Gehirn halt einfach, guck weg. Ja. Also ich weiss ja, ob du das manchmal hörst, du guckst in die Sonne und das Gehirn so. Don't. Einmal wegbeten. Hey, hallo. Hallo, hallo, einmal kurz wegschauen bitte. Check, check, check, check, Frankie. Du, pass auf, folgendes. Ja, ich krieg hier gerade von der Retina einiges rein und guck mal, kurze Seite. Oder halt Augenlider zu, aber wo er geht nicht zu. Was ich total spannend finde, wo ich auch drüber nachdenke, was wenn das Menschen hätten, Pferdeohren. Die können ja so sich wegdrehen. Die können ja in die Richtung sich drehen, in die sie hören wollen. Wenn das Menschen hätten, könntest du immer sehen, wenn jemand gar keinen Bock auf dich hat, wenn er einfach so das Ohr von dich plötzlich wegdreht, einfach so 180 Grad weg. Kannst du das auch so ein bisschen,
glaube ich. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das wäre eigentlich ganz gut.
Guck mal, hinter dir.
Kannst du einfach so hinter dich hören.
Hör mal hinter dich.
Wie praktisch.
Schau mal hinter dir, sag mal. Hör mal hinter dir.
Hör mal nach links. Hör mal nach oben.
Sag mal nicht. Man sagt, schau mal, schmeck mal nach links.
Schmeck mal kurz hinter dich, bitte.
Riech mal hinter dich.
Hier ist so ruhig, da war es die ganze Zeit laut.
Bei mir war es auch laut. Also ich meine dieses irgendwie, dieses De la Muerto ist ja Halloween. Also zu ähnlichem.
Si, si, si, claro. Comprende, compresa Alemania. Mi si claro, el fuego. Aber ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit wie Halloween. Ja. Ich habe Halloween auch nur dadurch mitbekommen, dass es laut war. Laut wurde, ja. Ansonsten habe ich das einfach dann so, dadurch kann man einfach in so einer Skala, wo an die Lautstärke, wo ist, die Feiertage rausfedern. Aber ansonsten habe ich nichts mitbekommen. Adams Family habe ich geschaut, schaue ich immer zu Halloween. Guter Film.
Bababam.
Das ist ein guter Film.
Macht immer Spaß.
Aber mehr auch nicht.
Ich will jetzt,
das ist mir
völlig unangenehm, aber ich habe mich gestern
gewogen
und ich habe eine Grenze überschritten, wo ich sage, das kann nicht sein. Diese Grenze habe ich nicht gedacht, dass ich die erlebe. Die Hunni oder was? Ich habe die dreistellige Grenze. Du hast eine Hunni? Mit Klamotten. Warum wiegst du dich mit Klamotten? Ich bin abends zu Hause und dachte mir, komm, jetzt mal wiegen. Jetzt mal schön auf die Waage stellen. Mit Pulli, tatsächlich aber auch mit Hose, ohne Schuhe, aber 100 Kilo genau.
Wow.
Und dann dachte ich mir, was, das kann nicht wahr sein.
Wann war deine erste 100?
16, glaube ich.
Aber dann habe ich im Internet nachgeguckt.
Aber ich sage mal, die erste 100 ist nichts im Vergleich zur zweiten.
Freu dich auf die zweite.
Die 200.
Ja, das ist normal. Und dann habe ich geguckt, was ich denn ist nichts im Vergleich zur zweiten. Freu dich auf die zweite. Die 200. Ja, das ist normal.
Und dann habe ich geguckt, was ich denn für ein Gewicht haben müsste bei immerhin 1,97.
Und dann stand da, dann bin ich mal runtergegangen.
Bei 100 stand leichtes Übergewicht, bei 97 stand Normalgewicht und bei 75 stand auch noch Normalgewicht. Okay. Und bei 74 stand leichtes Untergewicht. Das heißt, ich muss, also ich kann theoretisch noch, ich kann 75 Kilo, ich kann 25 Kilo weniger wiegen als jetzt und hätte noch Normalgewicht. Holy smokes, ich muss dringend Sport machen. Ich dachte, ein bisschen Maya-Pyramiden beklettern reicht. Ja, und ich würde dir die sieben Burritos-Reimpfeffers daneben. Die sind so gesund, da ist Salat drin, Fleisch drin, Brot drin, so gut. Was ist eigentlich aus deinem Bild geworden? Komischerweise haben mir Leute ganz oft geschrieben, so hey, also erstmal soll ich dir mitteilen, dass es nicht ungewöhnlich ist, dass bei diesen Speditionsfirmen niemand rangeht. Gut, also ist mitgeteilt. Das ist häufig passiert. Mir sagen viele Leute nämlich Dinge, die dich betreffen. Ich weiß nicht, was los ist. Niemand weiß, wer wir uns auch nicht mehr vorstellen seit 80 Folgen. Weiß niemand mehr, wer wer ist. Du bist Stefan, ich bin Florentin. Das kann gut sein. Das stimmt, da bin ich noch gar nicht drauf gekommen, dass die Leute uns vielleicht wirklich verwechseln. Wenn du bei Folge 15 eingestiegen bist, weißt du nichts über uns. Wollen wir uns noch mal vorstellen, vielleicht für alle noch mal? Okay, also dann fangen wir an. Okay, ja, also mein Name ist Stefan, ich bin 24 Jahre alt mittlerweile, ich bin nicht mehr 19, war ein Running Gag damals, hört mal rein in die früheren Folgen. Ja, ich bin 1,97 groß, habe, wie soll ich sagen, dunkelblonde Haare, bin in der Nähe des Ruhrgebiets aufgewachsen und ja, ich freue mich sehr, dass ich hier sein darf und bin gespannt, was ihr alle so sagt. Und wenn du dich jetzt mal so mit drei Adjektiven beschreiben würdest? Spritzig, frisch und irre. Okay, und welche Musik hörst du gerne?
Ich höre wahnsinnig gerne klassische Musik, wahnsinnig gerne Filmsoundtracks.
Ich höre aber auch gerne Rockmusik, zum Beispiel sowas wie The Who gefällt mir sehr gerne.
Okay, kannst du jetzt mal deine Leidenschaft für Rockmusik in so einen Ruf, so einen Rock'n'Roll-Ruf?
Yeah, hey Rock'n'Roll! Geuf. Hey, Rock'n'Roll!
Geil, krass, ja, cool. Ja, freut mich. Ja, herzlich willkommen, Stefan. Dankeschön. Ja, was ist denn mit dir, Florentin? Ja, also wie schon gesagt, ich heiße Florentin. Genau, bin in Bayern geboren, wohne jetzt hier in Köln und Hamburg manchmal und ja, bin 27 Jahre alt und ich habe ja, also verschiedene, ja. Gut, Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Genau, nur kurz, damit ihr wisst, wer wir sind. Ähm, genau. Diese Sache mit dem Bild.
Ähm, kurz ... Nur kurz, damit ihr wisst, wer wir sind. Genau. Diese Sache mit dem Bild. Kurz noch mal Recap. Stefan hat sich ein sündhaft teures Bild ersteigert. Ein sündhaft teures, potthässliches Bild. Das aber noch nicht, und das ist tatsächlich interessant. Ich habe heute noch mal auf der Puffopide nachgeschaut. Bis jetzt wurde es noch nicht geleakt. Nein. Die Öffentlichkeit kennt nicht das Bild, das Stefan ersteigert hat. Niemand weiß, wie es aussieht. Ich habe es einem, ich habe mir gedacht, ich schicke es niemandem ausser einem. Einem habe ich es dann geschickt auf Nachfrage, aber bislang ist es noch nicht geleakt. Wow, das ist das Tolle an der Podcast-Ufo-Community. Ihr haltet dicht, und das ist schön. Oder ihr hasst euch. Und deswegen teilt ihr nicht. Und ihr wisst nicht, wie man Bilder im Internet hochlägt. Das kann alles sein. Genau, ich habe ein Bild ersteigert in einem Auktionshaus und bin da hingefahren, habe nicht genau abschliessen können, was diese Maßen bedeuten. Ich habe aber auch nicht richtig nachgeschaut. Das Bild habe ich dann mit, ich habe mir einen großen Lkw geliehen, bin da hingefahren in Düsseldorf, dann wurde ich schon begrüßt mit den Worten, ah, haben Sie jetzt ein passendes Fahrzeug? Sie sind vollidiot. Die haben es mir reingetragen, ich bin zu mir gefahren, habe das rausgetragen, alleine, dabei ist es mir so komischerweise gegen den Rand des Lkw. Aber hattest du Styropor? Nein, gar nicht. Keine Styropor-Ecken, gar nicht. Den ist es scheißegal. Aber ohne Rahmen. Naja, es ist Leinwand halt. Es ist eine grosse Leinwand. Und deswegen brauchst du ja keinen Rahmen. Und dann habe ich es genommen, reingetragen und jetzt hängt es bei mir zu Hause. Und nimmt die ganze Wand meines Wohnzimmers ein und es sieht aus wie ein Museumsraum, der eigens dafür hergerichtet wurde, dieses Bild auszustellen. Kennst du es wirklich komplett abschlüssig, einfach eine Wand, das stelle ich mir so gut vor.
Nee, nee, ich zeige es dir mal gerade.
Das ist es.
Rechts daneben ist ein grosses Bild zur Foscale.
Aber ist schon schön.
Ja, ja, ja, es trifft jetzt nicht ganz meinen Geschmack, das musst du selber entscheiden. Bist du zufrieden damit? Ja, sehr. Ich finde es auch wirklich wahnsinnig schön. Ja? Ja. Ich bin ein Fan. Das ist genau die Art Stil, die mir gefällt. Aber es ist schon wirklich schön. Ich mag es sehr gerne. Die Farben passen auch sehr gut in die Wohnung. Hätte auch hinten losgehen können. Es war ja mehr so ein Testgebot. Ich ich habe das abgeholt und das hängt jetzt bei mir.
Vielen Dank für die vielen Angebote. Ja, vielen Dank,
es reicht jetzt aber auch. Und ich habe
tatsächlich, ich wollte auch ein Bild in meinem Zimmer haben.
Ich bin ja in Köln in eine WG
gezogen und das war für mich so ein Punkt,
ich fange ein neues Leben an. So, ich bin jetzt
wirklich auch ein, man hat ja manchmal
so den Wunsch. Bist du jetzt in eine WG gezogen?
Nee, vor langer, langer Zeit. Und man hat ja manchmal so den Wunsch,
sich selbst zu überwinden, so das alte Ich zurückzulassen und sagen so, nee, ich setze mich jetzt mit denen jeden Abend an den Küchentisch und rede mit denen und entwickle tief schürfende Freundschaften und auch rede auch mal über so Politik oder sowas und rede mit denen und so, ey, wie läuft das Studium und so und ich wirklich dann auch mal so ein Kalur nebenbei weg trinken. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, anfangen werde ich diese Reise mit einem Bild. Ich will ein Bild in meinem Zimmer haben, weil ich lebe sehr karg, ich habe fast nichts. Du lebst wie ein Gefängnisinsaschen. Nee, ich glaube, deutsche Gefängnisinsassen, wo so die Betonung auch auf Resozialisierung liegt, da lebst du weit drunter unter dem Standard. Ja, total. Also stellt euch so Tower of London vor, so wirklich so Gorte, so Kerke. Du hast kein Bett, also das ist wirklich, ich habe viele Diskussionen mit dir geführt, warum Betten gut sind. Nee, bin ich da lange nicht. Aber alles hat dich nicht interessiert, wie viel Wasser man verliert nachts, nein, du hast kein Bett. Hab kein Bett. Und mein erster Schritt, neuer Mensch zu werden, war, ich will ein Bild in meinem Zimmer hängen haben. Ich will wirklich ein wohnliches Zimmer und hab ein Bild, aber ich
wollte kein Bild kaufen, deswegen habe ich
ein Bild selber gemalt. Ich habe
selber ein Bild gemalt, das in meinem
Zimmer hing und seit
bis heute in meinem Zimmer immer noch hängt.
Hast du das eigentlich jemals gesehen?
Nee, was hast du gemalt?
Du hast versucht, was nachzumalen.
Aus der Eric-Andre-Show. Genau, ich habe das Bild aus der Eric-Andre-Show nachgemalt. Ja. Das ist so rot und dann drei beige Rahmen ineinander. Ja, ja, ja. Aber ist es gelungen? Würdest du sagen, es ist gelungen? Naja, es sind ja einfach nur geometrische Formen und dann hab ich das halt so abgeklebt mit Krepppapier und hab das halt nachgezogen. Das Problem ist halt, dass es gar nicht so leicht ist, eine gleichmäßige Farbe hinzubekommen. Vor allem, wenn du die mischen musst. Wenn du die mischen musst und dann die auch so aufzutragen, dass man keine Schlieren sieht und so. Das ist auch nicht so leicht und dann hast du halt teilweise die drüber und so. Aber das war tatsächlich erfolgreich. Bis heute habe ich das drinstehen. Ich habe mir beim Baumarkt einfach die größte Leinwand gekauft, die die hatten. Die hatten aber nur noch eine Leinwand übrig und die war so ein bisschen geknickt. Ist das knickt? Da dachte ich mir auch so, ja, aber ich kann jetzt nicht einen kleineren nehmen. Wenn du schon ein Bild malst, dann mal ein grosses, glaube ich, ist es von Picancho, Picasso. Von Detective Picasso. Um mal ein paar Meter eben, wenn sie dich verhinden. Und habe dann das Bild gemalt. Das ist ja auch oft so, das ist ja so ein psychologischer Effekt, dass du das letzte Ding nicht nehmen willst. Ja. Zum Beispiel muss ja in Deutschland müssen Bäckereien, also so Bäckereien in Supermärkten, so im Eingangsbereich Supermärkten, wenn du reinkommst, hast du nicht noch mal so eine Bäckerei. Die müssen ja bis zum Ladenschluss dafür sorgen, dass ihre Auslage komplett gefüllt ist. Was zur Hölle? Warum? Weil die damit sicherstellen, dass du nicht diesen, ah, das ist das letzte Stück, das nimmt eh niemand mehr. Weil die meinem Gefühl zuvorkommen wollen? Ja, die verkaufen mehr, wenn die Regale voll sind. Weil die Leute dann das Gefühl haben, ah, ich habe gute Auswahl, ich kriege noch was Gutes. Wohingegen, wenn nur noch so ein krümeliges Kuchenstück da ist, dann kauft es niemand mehr. Und der Kuchen selber ist ja wertlos, Hauptsache die kaufen noch ein Stück. Und wenn dann die letzten Elf weggeschmissen werden, ist egal. Das war so weird, ganz kurzer Einschub, weil mir gerade einfällt. Das Brot kaufen in Mexiko ist, also hört mir, das Land soll mal bitte kurz zuhören, weil es ist so einfach zu beheben, dieses massive Problem, was ihr da habt. Also, da liegen überall, ich bin in einen Riesensupermarkt reingelaufen, der hieß Chedraui oder ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man es ausspricht, C-H-E-D-R-A-U-I. Keine Ahnung, war für mich einfach, ich habe die ganze Zeit einfach das nicht akzeptiert als Wort, mein deutsches Gehirn.
Da bin ich da reingelaufen und es war ein riesen Supermarkt, wie so Metrogrösse, aber halt ein Supermarkt.
Und dann gab es eine Abteilung, das Land, das Brotland, da waren überall verschiedene Brote und so ein riesen Haufen mit Kuchen.
Da habe ich im Nachhinein erst verstanden, dass das der Dia de los Muertos, der toten Kuchen ist. Und alle Familien sind zur Kasse gegangen, hatten diesen Kuchen. Jede einzelne Familie hat diesen Kuchen in der Hand. Was ist das für ein Kuchen? So ein Hefekuchen, so süsser Hefekuchen. Habe ich mal probiert, gar nicht mal so gut. Aber einfach wie so ein, ach so, okay. So ein großer Hefering, so süss. Ein bisschen wie ein Sankt-Martins-Bretzel, nicht so ganz so geil als Kuchen. Das klingt wiederum ganz gut. Also der kleinste deutsche Feiertag, Sankt Martins, hat besseres Essen als der größte mexikanische Feiertag. Nee, das wollte ich nicht damit sagen. Nein, das hast du damit zu sagen. Und dann liegt überall in diesem Brotland, wie in einem offenen Backwerk, halt einfach verschiedene Boden rum. Sehr viel Auswahl. Und überall sagen Zangen dabei, bei den verschiedenen Sorten. Ich habe aber nicht gefunden, wo soll ich diese... Da liegen überall Zangen, okay. Ich habe diese Tüten gesucht die ganze Zeit. Wo sind die Tüten, mit denen man dann zur Kasse geht und dann guckt die sich an und dann tippt die das in die Kasse ein und dann kannst du es mitnehmen. Gab es nicht. Ich bin da wirklich in den Halbsprung rumgelaufen, dann habe ich gesehen, da ist eine Art Parallelkasse. Und da an dieser Parallelkasse ist ein großer Stapel an Tabletts. Und dann nimmst du dir ein Tablett, wo noch so Kuchenreste von dem Vorgänger drauf waren. Dann nimmst du so einen Riesen, das ist wahnsinnig schwer, weil so ein Gusseisernes Tablett ist, riesig groß auch. Das nimmst du dir, das ist wahnsinnig schwer an sich schon, packst dann da deine ganzen Brötchen drauf mit den Zangen, die da rumliegen, nimmst alles, was du willst und dann stellst du dich an bei dieser Parallelkasse. Und die ist lächerlich voll. Warum? Weil da jemand ist, der große Papiertüten hat, dann diese großen Tabletten, die schweren Gusseiseln-Tabletten in Empfang nimmt, mit einer Zange bei sich dann noch eine Zange nimmt und dann von dem Tablett in eine große Tüte macht und das einzelne in die Kasse eintippt, wiegt diese Tüte auf, wenn dich zumacht,
dann, wie du das von der Fleischstücke kennen, so ein Etikett vorne drauf machst,
der das gibt, und dann kannst du den Einkauf fortsetzen,
und dann kannst du damit zur Kasse gehen und das bezahlen. Das ist lächerlich.
Das ist lächerlich.
Niemand mag Kassen in Supermärkten.
Und du stehst eine halbe Stunde an, bis diese Frau diese ganzen Brötchen einpackt, einzeln noch mal.
Die muss jedes einzelne Brötchen, jedes einzelne Brötchen mit einer Zange anfassen, weil die darfst du ja nicht selber anfassen dann, um diese Tüte zu packen. Das ist bescheuert. Und du gehst einfach drei Stunden bis in den Supermarkt. Und ich bin jeden Tag im Hellen in den Supermarkt gegangen und bin rausgegangen, es war dunkel. Das war wirklich weird, das ist ein System, was broken ist. Ich glaube aber, du sprichst ja, glaube ich, ein großes Thema der Völkerverständigung an. Es bräuchte so ein Ministerium für gute Ideen. Ja, wir haben hier was gelöst. Ja, genau. Krankenversicherung, Deutschland ebt die Hand, wir haben da ein gutes System. Hat sich jahrelang bewährt, weil es relativ spät entwickeln muss. Wir kriegen das hin. Leute, schaut mal bei uns. Oder so, hey Leute, die Ampel. Nur Ampel. Oder die Franzosen, Kreisverkehre, Leute, Kreisverkehre. Aber das Problem ist, wie macht man das? Also das Problem ist, du wirst halt als Land arrogant angeschaut, wenn wir jetzt als die Deutschen sagen, wir schicken jetzt einfach einen Deutschen in jedes Land der Welt und das geht einfach zu dem Regierungsoberhaupt und sagt, pass auf, was wir ganz gut machen, missionarisch, also ja, es ist schon, aber einfach nur mal so auf den Teller legen, einfach nur mal so brainstormen, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, bei euch stirbt jeder Zweite an Syphilis, vielleicht habt ihr da irgendwas falsch gemacht. Aber eigentlich müsste es jedes Land machen, dass auch irgendwie die Peruaner zu uns kommen und sagen, hier, so, keine Ahnung, wir haben ja diesen Softcake. Alpak uns jahrelang Riesenprobleme. Ja, ja. Jetzt haben wir es, Problema, jetzt haben wir es gelöst. Bueno, nehmt es auch an, wir sagen, wir haben keine Alpakas. Es gab ja auch diesen großen Finanzskandal mit dem großen Steuerbetrug, Cum-Ex, wo dann auch irgendwie ein europäisches Land hat es gecheckt und ist denen auf die Schliche gekommen, aber die konnten in anderen europäischen Ländern einfach weitermachen, weil die Finanzämter nicht miteinander gesprochen haben. Und das ist ja total bescheuert, weil dann das gleiche Prinzip müsste man auf alles übertragen, weil es gibt bestimmt Kuchenbetrüger in diesem Land. Es gibt hundertprozentig Kuchenbetrüger in diesem Land. Und es gibt auch italienische Kuchenbetrüger und französische Kuchenbetrüger. Aber wenn wir nicht zusammenarbeiten, dann kriegen wir das nie unter Kontrolle. Das heißt, wir bräuchten so ein Aus... Und ich würde so gerne mal so eine Lidl-Tüte mitnehmen, die so durchsichtig ist. Ja, und immer so den mexikanischen Tats überhaupt so auf den Teller, auf den Tisch. Und sagen, okay, das war's. Arrivando. Nee, das müsst ihr nicht nehmen. Einfach mal die Hände hochnehmen und sagen, guckst du mal an, wenn du Fragen hast, fragt. Vielleicht so anonym an die Botschaft schicken, einfach mit so einem Zwinker-Smiley. Ich lasse mal meine Nummer hier und mal gucken, was sie sagen. Und ob die dann nach einem Jahr wieder hinfahren und gucken, ob sie jetzt auch diese durchsichtigen Tüten nehmen, wo jeder seine Brötchen reinmacht und dann kann an der Kasse jemand sofort sehen und muss es nicht wieder verpacken. Du hast ja die Zange schon, wenn du das Brot schon in der Zange hast. Dann kannst du es ja einfach in die Tüte tun. Ich war kurz davor zu sagen, Leute, die Zangen sind nicht euer Problem. Ich will euch nicht meine europäische Denkweise aufoktroyieren. Ja, ja. Das Ministerium für gute Ideen. Jedes Land braucht ein Ministerium für gute Ideen. Und die tauschen sich dann einfach aus und sagen, guck mal, was macht ihr denn denn gut und dann lässt man einfach so einfach austauschen. In jedem Land sind Systeme kaputt. Ja. Und ich glaube aber insgesamt haben sehr viele Länder Antworten gefunden auf Dinge, weil manche Länder haben verschiedene Schwerpunkte gehabt. Deutschland hat halt so einen Ingenieurschwerpunkt gehabt, Amerika hat den Unterhaltungsvorsprung gehabt. Und da muss man einfach mal so ein bisschen gucken, dass man sich einfach mal updatet. Also du meinst, dass dann so ein amerikanischer Showrunner zu uns kommt und sich so eine Late-Night-Show mal guckt und sagt, vorne macht das alles falsch. Ja, oder so ein amerikanisches Streaming-Unternehmen, einfach mal in anderen Ländern auch Serien produziert zum Beispiel. Das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, diese Vorstellung. Da habe ich letztens auf DVD-Elvers gelesen. Hugogon Balder soll ja jetzt tatsächlich noch eine neue Sendung machen auf Sat.1. Nein, aber das, was ich sagen will, ist, es ist doch toll, wenn die jetzt anfangen, in anderen Ländern quasi mit dem Geld, was sie haben und mit dem System, was sie etabliert haben und was bei denen sich bewährt hat, in anderen Ländern was zu machen. Ja, aber sind Serien noch cool? Ich weiß nicht, ich finde mittlerweile hat Amazon Prime auch so viele geile Serien. Weiß ich nicht. Ich komme schon alleine nicht durch diese mies programmierte Seite. Aber Sky, alleine Sky, Succession, mega geile Serie, Game of Thrones sowieso, so viele geile Serien. Ja, tut sich jetzt mit Netflix zusammen, ich glaube, da kann ich ruhigem Gewissen sagen, super, toll. Du hast ja mitgeschrieben bei der Serie, die bald rauskommt, auf Netflix, deutsche Serie. Gibt es in der Serie eine Traumsequenz? Glinzeln mich jetzt entweder einmal an für Ja oder zweimal für Hilfe. Eine Traumsequenz meinst du? Ja, gibt es eine Traumsequenz? Was ist ja?
Ich wiederhole die Frage, was ist nein?
Ja ist einmal blinzeln, nein ist zweimal blinzeln.
Eine Reaktion ist mir vertraglich untersagt.
Ich kann es so einfach nicht mehr sehen. Jede fucking Serie hat Traumsequenzen.
Jede. Und jede Serie wird achronologisch erzählt. In jeder Serie hat man Flashbacks. In jeder Serie hat man Flashbacks zu Kindheit. Frag noch mal die Frage. Gibt es in deiner Serie Flashbacks? Ach so, was im Auge? Ich habe mein Auge zuckt. Vor allem, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass Serien wieder schlechter werden. Ich glaube wirklich, Serien werden wieder schlechter. Weil ich schaue gerade auch Sopranos an. Einfach Sopranos, eine No-Bullshit-Serie. Einfach A passiert, dann passiert B, dann passiert C, and that's fucking it. Oh, Dr. Netflix. Hast keine Flashbacks, keine Voice-overs, keine Visionen, keine Träume, keine Oh, ist das, was die Person sieht, jetzt real oder nicht? Es sind diese ganzen Narrativen Mittel, die sich so abgegriffen haben, die einfach so jetzt irgendwie auch die neue Staffel House of Cards. House of Cards hatte nie diese ständigen Flashbacks zu Wie war Frank Underwood in der Kindheit eigentlich? So, ah, der wurde als Kind gemobbt, also ist er jetzt machtgeil. Die aktuelle Staffel hat das, obwohl sie es nie gebraucht hat. Wo läuft House of Cards? Netflix. Ich habe nichts gegen diese neue Staffel zu sagen, außer dass ich sie fantastisch finde. Wann kann man denn die Serie sehen? Nächstes Jahr. Nächstes Jahr? Das ist ja gar nicht mehr so lange hin. Nee, weiss es nicht. Ich bin zum ersten Mal in dieser Lage, wo ich nicht weiß, was kann ich sagen. Mal gucken. Bald bestimmt mehr. Du wirst auf jeden Fall so beides mögliches alles aufklären und Fragen nachvollziehen. Klar, wir können auch mal so eine Audiokommentarsache machen. Ja, gerne, auf jeden Fall, da kommentieren wir beide die gesamte Staffel und nicht nur so, aha, okay, und wie hast du das gemacht, wie hast du das so brillant hinbekommen? Und dieser Flashback, was soll der fucking Scheiß? Nee, ich bin gespannt, ich freue mich da sehr drauf, wenn ich da mehr drüber sagen darf und ihr mir davon sehen könnt. Gut, es gibt in Sopranos eine Koma-Sequenz, wo er lange im Koma ist, okay. Aber das ist auch erst Staffel sechs. Apropos, wo du gerade dabei warst, schon mal, prophylaktisch zu verhindern, dass Leute schreiben. Wir kommen zur Rubrik Gegendarstellung. Wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, dingelilingeliling, tut uns leid. Sorry, Gegendarstellung. Hefe sind keine Bakterien. Tut uns leid. Hefe ist ein fucking Pilz. Am besten hat mir der Kommentar gefallen, der einfach Pilz unter die Folge geschrieben hat. Und ich wusste sofort, ja, klar, er ist ein Pilz. Dankeschön, das hilft. Nicht, ich bin Professor für Hefe und ich habe das in Asien studiert und deswegen weise ich, dass es, es ist glaube ich tatsächlich eine Art, das hat einer geschrieben, einer der Organismen, die uns sehr, die menschenähnlicher sind noch als Bakterien. Das heisst, also zum einen weil es Pilz, ich, Pilz als Organismus ist, ist schon näher als Bakterium. Aber das fand ich sehr gruselig, dass dieses Seltsame, dieser Würfel, menschenähnlicher ist als Bakterien, fand ich gruselig. Möchte nicht weiter darüber nachdenken. Ich habe mir auch seitdem nicht mehr mal Brötchen gemacht abends. Kleine Brötchen. Boah, jetzt ist es aber auch hier viel. Dieser Herr Netflix war wieder wieder. Dieses Kai-Ton. Welche Anrufe haben achtmal? Ach, scheiße. Mittlerweile haben wir das Gefühl, wir werden hier ein bisschen sabotiert. Und man versteckt immer unsere Mikrofone hier. Ich dachte, es wäre ein pädagogisches Mittel, ein pädagogisches Stilmittel des Lektionerteilens, weil wir lassen das immer ein bisschen rumstehen, muss man sagen. Wir gehen nicht so mega gut um mit dem Material. Und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es mal weggeschoben wird, wurde auch schon mal weggeschoben. Und dann wurde gesagt, ja, und das wird passiert, wenn er es immer so rumstehen lässt, dann wird es jemand klauen. Und dann sagt man, ja, sorry, Entschuldigung. Ja, wir versprechen es nicht mehr zu machen. Sorry, Dennis. Und dann bringt das einen wieder und dann stand sie nur hinter dem Vorhang. Und das war gerade wieder weg. Du warst aber kein freches Kind oder kein ungezogenes Kind. Nee, ich war wahnsinnig anstrengend, glaube ich, weil ich die kontinuierlich gesprochen habe und Phasen hatte, in denen ich meine Tante sagt immer, es gab immer diesen Familienmittwoch. Und jeden Mittwoch bin ich aus meiner Heimatstadt mit meinen Eltern nach Dortmund gefahren, wo meine Oma gewohnt hat. Und da kam mein Cousin und meine Cousine immer zusammen, drei Familien und haben uns mit Oma getroffen, die drei Kinder, meine Oma. Und jeden Mittwoch hatte ich ein anderes Kostüm an, habe eine andere Rolle personifiziert und eine andere Phase gehabt. Meistens war das verbunden mit einem Film, den ich gesehen habe, einem Stück, was ich gesehen habe, oder einem Was-is-was-Buch, das mir geschenkt wurde oder so. Wenn Oma mir Mittwoch ein Tut-er-nicht-Armung-Buch, das habe ich immer noch geschenkt, hat, halte ich den Mittwoch darauf so eine Ägypter-Phase und bin dann mit so einem Pharaon-Scheiss. Das war wahnsinnig anstrengend, glaube ich.
Und du hast dann Pharao gespielt? Der achtjährige Stefan war ein Pharao-Stefan?
Klar, und dann mussten auch alle mitmachen und so einen Scheiss.
Dann habe ich immer alle in so Rollenspielen eingebunden.
Das ist fast anstrengender als frech. Dann lieber ein Arschloch.
Ja, ja, ja. Dann lieber irgendwie so einmal im Jahr von der Polizeistatt abgeholt werden. Ja, genau.
Anstatt ständig irgendwie, Aladin, Aladin, halt deine Scheißfresse! Ja, aber zumindest so eine Dino-Phase hatte doch jeder. Eine Ritterphase, eine Dino-Phase, Polizeiphase. Ja. Wo man nur einmal kurz alle Dinos auswendig konnte. Und dann bin ich in die Schule gekommen. Und das Erste, was der Biolier gesagt hat, war irgendwie, ja, wir müssen jetzt die scheisse Dinosaurier durchnehmen, was soll uns das bringen, ich hab da gar keinen Bock drauf. Das heißt hier, und dann dachte ich mir, jetzt fragt er bestimmt. Mit deinem Dino-Hut. Ja, und ich so, Mann, das kann doch nicht sein. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt stellt er wenigstens die Fragen, wie diese verschiedenen Dinosaurier heißen, aber er ist schon da einfach, ja, ist der Bachiosaurus, Ankylosaurus, Pyrrhanogon.
Nein, du konntest glänzen.
Scheiße, fuck, das hätte die Dinosaurier nicht richtig glänzen können.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass wir in der Schule die Dinosaurier gelernt haben, ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, was hat man bei euch gelernt?
Ich finde es total verrückt, dass man, also ich erinnere mich, dass wir im Geschichtsunterricht wirklich chronologisch angefangen haben.
Ja, ja.
In meinen Augen ist das nicht die beste Art, Geschichte zu lernen, zu sagen, wir fangen beide in der Steinzeit an.
Das ist ein sehrern anfangen. Ja, das war gestern. Gestern war Mathe, die ersten beiden. Geschichte. Aber einfach irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dass man irgendwo anfängt, wo es aufregend ist und nicht in der Steinzeit, wo man einfach sagt, ja, dann ist ein Blitz eingeschlagen und dann gab es Feuer und dann hatten die Feuer. Und dann haben die einen Gott angebildet, der Blitze macht. Aber wir wissen nicht, wie der Gott hieß. Und dann haben die die Sachen gemalt an die Wand, vielleicht aber auch nicht. Oder wir fahren jetzt ins Neandertal und gucken uns an, wie die gelebt haben. Und die ganz klasse Yeah! Vielleicht ist aber auch eine Fälschung. Vielleicht hat uns französische Paläunchologen gefälscht im Jahre 1602. Wow, das klingt toll! Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, wir sind noch in der Bronzezeit. Und dann kam die Bronzezeit und alle so, was ist Bronze? So, das ist der Zeitpunkt, wo sich die Kaffeemaschine abstellt, wo wir durch sind mit der Folge. Das war unser großes... Das ist wieder wahnsinnig spät. Unsere grosse 150. Folge. Unser grosses Jub Jubiläum. Jan Bimmermann, 150, wir chillen und uns ist alles scheißegal.
Also falls ihr euch gefragt habt, wow, was haben sie vorbereitet für die Folge 150, für das große Jubiläum, nichts.
Man muss dazu sagen, wir haben nächste Woche aber auch den nächsten Live-Auftritt in Hamburg.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Kommt alle vorbei? Also alle die Tickets haben? Ja genau, kommt bitte vorbei, sonst wird es echt unangenehm. Und da haben wir tolle Sachen vorbereitet. Mit tollen Gästen und Musiknummern und wirkt mich ab, wirkt mich ab, wirkt mich ab. Das wird fantastisch. Auch noch vielen Dank für das Intro an Chris. Ihr Name einfügen. Wir sprechen das dann später ein. Ansonsten haut rein, vielen Dank. Spricht das mal noch selber wieder ein?
Spricht das denn ein?
Ansonsten vielen Dank.
Nee, baust du dir dein Mikrofon zu Hause auf?
Und macht's gut, vielen Dank, haut rein, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Danke, wem ab.